and I had a phase in my life where I
used to
smuggle hashish out of India and I used
to go to the Crawford Market in Bombay
with kilos of gold strapped on my body
and the Crawford Market is just a
labyrinth the millions of teeming people
and I would they would tell me go to the
second Crossroad in Duncan's lane and
then dismiss your cab and I would do
that and then there would be a a child
there who would take me by the hand and
lead me through this labyrinthy streets
to this
Muslim gangster called the baby elephant
uh this huge guy drenched in perfume
with all of his lieutenants around him
and they were always very happy to see
me because we were going to do business
they have more hash than they knew what
to do with I had gold which they wanted
they were very helpful and yet you know
this was a criminal Enterprise fraught
with danger and I never fully trusted
them and also we had to smoke enormous
amounts of hashif to complete these
deals so you're always trying to get as
loaded as you possibly could but also
perfectly aware that at their pleasure
they could kill you in a moment in the
consequences would be nil because they
had the whole city of Bombay paid off so
it was this ambiguous thing and and the
and the and the Elves and the general
um mythology of elves is like this you
know elves respect intelligence the way
they relate to intelligence is they set
you riddles elves are about language if
you're stupid they make you sleep for a
hundred years at the center of their
Hills and don't let you go back if you
can riddle their riddle and riddle in
return then they think you're a fine
fellow and they let you crawl back to
the pub or whatever it is so there is
this there the word that I use to
describe the my feeling about the DMT
space is it's zaning
it's like it's like a coyote cartoon or
a Marx Brothers film it's a land of
explosions and falling animals and yet
it's all for fun but you have the
feeling that these guys play so rough
that their idea of fun might also
include the possibility of handing you
four sticks of dynamite on a short fuse
just because it would be so amusing to
do that so it's uh it's got a funny
emotional vibe to it it's lots of fun
but you really want to be on your toes
and to try and get as much out of it as
you can one idea that I've played with
about what's going on is there is again
extrapolating from these hashish deals
in India it seemed to me they were like
mean Traders
memes you know are the smallest units of
an idea or an ideology well it's like
they they're in there and they show you
all this stuff and it's the equivalent
of trade goods you know beads and
bobbles to trade with the natives in
Newtonian space and they're saying
wouldn't you like this wouldn't you like
this and you're like some poor Amazonian
Indian being shown fountain pens that
when you turn them upside down lay these
undressed and stuff like that saying my
Lord I've never seen anything like that
I must possess it
but what we have that they want I'm not
sure uh what it is we can offer them
yeah
[Music]
do you feel like if you were less on
your toes than you should be you would
be in any danger I mean you also said at
one point that you felt tremendous
affection from me as well it's assuming
they're going to take care of you
it's almost like the problem of a child
playing with a spider or something they
have affection for you but they don't
really understand how you work they
don't really understand your limits
you know and they might just simply
shoot past your limits by accident than
leave you a quaking wreck in some Asylum
for the rest of your life and they'll
feel very badly about it but you know
it's just a case of a misstep
no it's never happened we've never lost
anybody I have had the experience of
turning people on to it and having them
you know go through the rapid eye
movement and all that and then come down
and say what happened and they say
absolutely nothing happened and
furthermore I'd rather not have anything
to do with you anymore
this is it I've had it and thanks and
please don't come around anymore you can
take your Elf machines and your whole
wrath and just fade from my life as
quickly as possible and I'd be perfectly
happy
then I accommodate in that case because
I really think that I like I've noticed
people who have that experience are
people who probably were a bad risk to
start with I get the feeling that if you
can't stand it you can't remember
it's almost there is a safety thing
there
but my hope is that through Ayahuasca
analogs and the spreading knowledge of
these new Botanical sources and by
inspiring
biochemists and generally by just
getting this out of the closet that will
begin to form a consensus I mean I've
been all over the world dug into all
kinds of strange stuff and this is the
weirdest thing this side of the yawning
grave without contests and yet it
appears perfectly harmless easily
accessed if you know the the route and I
just don't see how human civilization
can continue to operate in ignorance of
these places it's very peculiar that it
is so little discussed and talked about
I would place it well I I think I said
the other night about human sexuality
you can hardly get through adulthood
into the grave without it confronting
you in some fashion or another because
we're enzymatically and hormonally wired
to have some confrontation with our
nature as sexual beings but this which
is equally profound and in some ways
more
well I don't know I mean more dramatic
uh millions and millions of people have
gone to the Grave without ever having it
enter their mind that such a thing is
possible so it's like a dashboard a
button on the dashboard of your
physiology and I think we should it's
part of the mystery of who we are it's
Central to the mystery of cognition mind
uh self-identity sexuality the whole
nine yards and yet probably 95 percent
of the human race never encounters it
unless everybody encounters it in the
act of dying but then what does that
mean if you can have a deep anticipation
of it and live your life in the light of
it simply by availing yourself of the
chemical means of of triggering I mean I
I think it inclines people toward
deep philosophical reflection on the
nature of Life Time being
self-identity language so forth and so
on it is the one thing that you
eventually are at sometime between age 7
and 12 we all become convinced that a
certain X Factor doesn't exist that we
have to lay it aside with the dreams of
childhood that where we bury the Easter
rabbit and Santa Claus we bury this
expectation well then when you smoke DMT
you just say my God you know the world
is made of Magic the primary reality is
a hidden magical unimaginable dimension
so it appears and yet our entire
civilization has been reared in
ignorance of this and we split the atoms
sequence DNA hurl machines outside the
solar system and apparently don't know
Jack's [ __ ] about Who We Are
bizarre
[Music]
foreign
[Music]